et l'encours a pris l'accent américain
ce week end sokal une équipe
californienne située à orange dans le
sud de los angeles c'était au complexe
sportif guy boniface pour disputer des
matches amicaux contre les équipes
féminines du club d'elancourt on a été
contacté par une association de
californie qui tous les ans fait un
périple à travers l'europe
quand on voit que dans leur périple
elles vont jouer à san sebastien
barcelone qu'elle joue à nice qu'elle
joue contre toulouse ou qu'elle joue
contre le racing club de france de venir
à elancourt wee cc on est on est on est
assez fiers de ça qu'ils aient choisi il
encourt pour venir aujourd'hui ray au
total une cinquantaine de joueuses
américaines évoluent en u16 u19 et
seniors a fait le déplacement pour
participer à ce mini tournoi
c'est vraiment une super expérience
d'être ici et de jouer avec d'autres
joueuses pour réaliser des matchs
intéressants
je joue dans cette équipe depuis sept
ans et j'ai visité différents pays je ne
suis jamais venu en france et c'est un
endroit où je voulais jouer
c'est vraiment excitant dans le match de
gala entre les deux équipes seniors les
amazones d'elancourt se sont inclinés 8
1 contre les californiennes une défaite
anecdotique pour le club
bah moi je trouve que c'est très
intéressant de jouer contre des équipes
déjà étrangères et en plus avec un si
bon niveau ça nous fait une bonne
expérience
non je trouve que franchement c'est bien
même si elles sont tactiquement et
physiquement au dessus de nous et j'en
fais une bonne expérience et ce comme ça
qu'on va apprendre en fait l'olympique
sporting-club d'elancourt prendre 70
adhérents dans ces sections féminines
un chiffre encore loin des standards
américains mais qui représente 10 % des
licenciés du club